PHIL: I mean everyone will
probably eat lunch.
It's just a matter of where they
eat it and who they eat
it with and if they
pay for it.
I mean, I'm sure everyone's
going to eat lunch on a day,
but some are going to have
to buy their own.
Some are going to be
dining with me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Yesterday in 5.301,
the students set up their
crystal growing experiments,
and some are growing fast.
JULIE: My crystal was
the first to form.
I think this is the largest
one I've seen so far.
So I thought I had won.
JOHN DOLHUN: Well, Julie
did get her crystal.
So I saw it with my own eyes.
NARRATOR: Other crystals are
growing too, but their owner
isn't looking.
When Jason finally checks up
on his crystals, they're
looking good.
TENGFEI: In this well, we have
several a single crystals, and
they are all big.
JASON: She had a crystal first,
but I haven't been
checking mine daily.
So I might have a
crystal first.
I don't know.
TENGFEI: Congratulations.
JASON: Thank you.
JULIE: I had a single crystal.
JASON: But I had multiple
single crystals.
JULIE: What?
JASON: I had multiple
single crystals.
JULIE: But my crystal
came first.
JASON:
JULIE: I'm not going
to bring it up.
I'm still the winner
as of right now.
JASON: I'm gonna bring it up.
I won.
I had the largest crystal.
I just didn't check it because
I didn't want to disturb it.
Mine is definitely
bigger, clearly.
JULIE: OK, but mine crystallized
like made a
single crystal first.
JASON: And like Julie was like,
I won, I won, I won.
I've got this tiny
little crystal.
I just got it first.
No.
The competition was the largest
crystal in one week period.
So I checked after one week.
JULIE: His fault for not talking
to Dr. Dolhun earlier.
So--
JASON: If I would have just like
looked at it earlier and
told Dr. Dolhun earlier, I have
a crystal growing, then I
would have won.
JOHN DOLHUN: But you see
yeah, Jason, if you
would have came forward--
JASON: I checked mine later.
And then I told Dr. Dolhun.
He was like, yeah,
but Julie won.
JOHN DOLHUN: We've already
declared a winner here.
JULIE: Mine.
Fantastic.
JASON: Julie rubs it in
my face all the time.
JULIE: I mean, I was already
declared the winner, so he
can't, yeah.
He's honorable mention.
NARRATOR: So Julie wins the
prize, lunch for her and a
friend or so she thinks.
PHIL: They both grew really
beautiful single crystals.
So the whole class got to enjoy
a lunch with the TAs and
the instructor.
PHIL: We ended up going to
Chinatown for dim sum.
And I have actually never
tried dim sum before.
So I got to try a lot
of new foods,
chicken feet, and tripe.
JASON: It's basically
the lining of a
cow's stomach, I think.
PHIL: It was good.
It was good.
I always enjoy trying new
food, so everyone had
a really good time.
I've never felt so close to
dying in my entire life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]